Alhamdulillah.
picking up where we left off in the book
of
seeking pardon and forgiveness from
Allah from
and
is mentioning select verses from the
Quran regarding the issue of
He mentions
the statement of Allah Subhanahu Waaala.
[Silence]
says, "And whoever does
something bad
or wrongs himself,
whoever does something sinful,
something bad, something evil and or
wrongs himself
and then seeks pardon and forgiveness
from Allah, he will find Allah to be
oft forgiving
Ever pardoning, most merciful
inah
verse number 33,
the disbelievers were
making a mockery of the Quran, making a
mockery of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
alaihi wasallam of Islam
and making dua
saying, "Oh Allah, if this is truly the
truth and this revelation and this Quran
is really from you,
then
torture us. Send down
stones upon our heads. Destroy us. bring
the annihilation
that you warn us of.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
responds to this
idiocy and he says Allah
would never punish them whilst you oh
Muhammad reside amongst them. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam resided
in Mecca.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
resided with these people and being that
he is amongst them Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala would never destroy them all in
such a fashion whilst he is amongst them
he says
and so what about when he's not amongst
them what about when he leaves them or
passes away, will they be destroyed
immediately upon his departure?
Allah says, "And Allah would not ever
torture them as long as they are seeking
pardon and forgiveness from Allah." The
protection
that
we are afforded
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is found
in our
seeking of forgiveness
the more a person seeks forgiveness
and repents to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
the safer he becomes. comes.
The more a person seeks forgiveness from
Allah, the safer and more distant the
person becomes from the punishment of
Allah.
[Silence]
He then mentions verse number 135 from
Alan
which translates to
Allah is speaking about the
the people of tawa. Who are the people
of tawa? One of their descriptions he
says they are those who upon
committing
some sin or wronging themselves they
remember Allah and immediately seek
forgiveness and pardon from Allah from
their sins upon remembering him. And
they believe
that none can remove the stains of sin
except for Allah.
And those are those who do not remain
stubborn upon upon
those wrong deeds, those sins whilst
they know they are doing such. A
believer is not someone who is
constantly
upon sin to the point where they forget
about it.
This is a type of
this is a type of
as the scholars tell us one of the ways
that a person treats something haram as
if it is halal as if they believe it's
halal. They do it and they consistently
do it and they don't think about it
again. Doesn't bother them because
they've been doing it for so long that
they do it as if Allah allows them to do
it. This is not the case of the
believer. A believer may sin. A believer
may repeatedly sin. However, a believer
is never numbed
by the by the sin that they are
committing. They will always feel guilty
about that sin. They will constantly
seek forgiveness for that sin. They will
constantly
have a guilty conscience. It will weigh
heavy on his mind. It is not something
that he does. And because he's been
doing it for so long and so much that it
doesn't even bother him anymore, it's
normal as if Allah made it halal. This
is a a very big problem. And this is one
of the meanings of the statement of the
prophet.
that a group from my nation will come to
declare intoxicants as lawful. How will
they make intoxicants lawful? Well, one
of the ways is that they will do it and
take these intoxicants so much and so
constantly that it's as if it's not
haram. Doesn't bother them a bit. They
never have a guilty conscience about it.
It's just how the world is. If you want
to be a really good Muslim, then you
should move to a Muslim country. That's
how things are here. We came here for a
particular thing, etc., etc. All the
discussions that people have when doing
something that is haram on a repeated
in a repeated manner.
A believer may do something wrong. He
may do something wrong a lot. He may
actually come to become addicted to that
haram thing. Person may sin. However,
the true difference is that the believer
is always irked by his sin and is always
aware of the dangers of constantly doing
something haram to the point where they
are so desensitized
by this haram that it doesn't even
register to them anymore that this is in
fact haram and a disobedience of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That's
all.